hello everyone Tinker Taylor Soldier
sailor Rich Man Poor Man beggar man
Thief I was thinking about that Nursery
room today as I tried to weigh up my
opinion of Sam bankman freed the man who
became a crypto billionaire before his
30th birthday vowed to give it all away
and is now standing trial for fraud and
conspiracy in a Manhattan Court original
or Reckless brilliant or just a
charlatan it's possible to attach any
number of conflicting adjectives to
bankman Fred's and his extraordinary
story and his meteoric rise and failure
luckily for us we have an author on
stage who's written a huge number of
bestsellers on some of the biggest
stories of our time and has watched the
story of Sam bankman freed unfold from
the inside Michael Lewis's books include
Flash Boys liar poker The Big Short and
Money Ball both made into successful
movies and his new book is going
infinite the rise and fall of a new
Tycoon it is his compelling take on the
story of Sam bankman freed so let's
begin Michael Lewis welcome first of all
I want to begin really simply by asking
how you came to meet Sam bankman freed
how did you get involved in all of this
so a lot of my books start accidentally
and this was no exception
uh September of
2021 I had a call from um a friend in
former book subject the main character
of Flash Boys uh asking me if I would
meet with this person who he was about
to do a business deal with the person
was Sam bankman freed I'd never heard of
him he said he was about to swap shares
in his company for shares in in s
bankman Freed's company FTX which I had
never heard of and he said um it's an
it's such an odd situation for me
because it's a big deal the this company
FTX is the fastest growing Financial
business I've ever seen um everybody in
our in our Circle sort of on board but
it's getting it's very hard for us to
get a read on who he is um he says I I
met with him I don't have a good feel
nobody he's he was the richest person in
the world under 30 at that point and he
said I called all over Wall Street and
nobody knows who he is so I said sure
and Sam bankman freed happened to have
grown up in the Bay area where I live
and he was visiting his parents and he
came over to see me um that been maybe a
month later and he tumbles out of an
Uber he looks like he tumbled out of a
dumpster he he's wearing his shorts and
his T-shirt and his and uh he's always
dressed for a hike but I think I was the
first one I ever took him on one and and
so we went on the walk in the Berkeley
Hills and after about an hour um I
ceased to really think very much about
my friend's interest and and started to
think about my own but because he was
the things that were coming out of his
mouth both how fast he had made it how
the world had respond I mean he was at
that point he was saying $ 22.5 billion
doar how the world was configuring
itself around his money what he intended
to do with the money um at the end of
the walk I just said I I don't know
where this is all going to end up but
could I just watch so you were impressed
I was so I there's a backstory to this
I had decided some years
ago and the last book I wrote the
premonition was the one result of this
that I was going to start books with a
character that I that the character in a
situation that I was going to cease to I
was going to let the story take care of
itself so what I thought after two hours
with him is I thought I have a this is a
character I don't know where it goes or
what it is but it's just it was so odd
it was peculiar and um the first thing I
you know it was months before I called
called up a a publisher and said maybe
I've got a book here I I and and what I
said to them I can remember what I said
I don't know I still didn't know what
the story was but it was there's a Sam
bman freed shaped hole in the world now
that I did not know exist I want to I
want to use him to describe that hole
and and so I thought he could take me
places and in particular so from that
walk the places I thought he could take
me I was really interested that he was a
spawn of Wall Street that he was he
especially very modern wall stre high
frequency trading had given him his
identity I thought it's a way into that
story like what is going on in markets
there he could take me there he take me
into American politics because he was SP
he was going he he was threatening to
spend a billion dollars in the next
presidential election and he was already
had already become B Biden's second
biggest donor uh and was meddling in all
kinds of interesting ways in
Congressional races I thought he could
take me into crypto I was crypto is on a
list of things I was interested in I had
not been that interested in it as people
crypto people had called me over the
years WR about us write about us because
they were always promoting themselves he
he was interesting because he was the
first crypto person person in crypto I
had met who didn't who didn't care all
that much about crypto he was agnostic
mostly they're religionists he had the
view that this is could all be BS it
could all fall apart H so I was thinking
like where he takes me uh and now he's
taking he ended up taking me a lot many
further places than I imagined he was
going to take me Journey may still be
continuing but let's pick up on a couple
of things you mentioned there so his
background his parents are academics you
talked about the fact that he was giving
money away so it was at University that
he became interested in this thing
called effective altruism just tell us a
little bit about this it it's a proper
kind of ideology that he got you people
are responsible for this comes out of
Oxford right it's it's uh I mean as I
understood it so he yes he had in
University without he was kind of had no
particular particular direction in life
he he was a son child of two Stanford
law professors and had kind of always
assumed he would be a professor of some
sort given his abilities he would have
been maybe a physics or a math teacher
but but uh but actually wasn't all that
interested in it two things happen to
him in University to give him Direction
one is he collides with these high
frequency traders who discover a curious
aptitude in him and we can talk about
what that is because it is a curious
aptitude but he also he also collides
with effective Alf M which is Young then
it's
2012 um and the it grow this is a
movement that grows out of
utilitarianism the the greatest good for
the greatest number but it it's and
there's a philosopher Oxford named Toby
Ward who gets the movement going by
making the point that at very little
inconvenience to himself if he directs
the money he gives away really smartly
effectively that he can do enormous good
and he writes a paper where he shows
that if he gives away half his salary
over his lifetime he will spare 880,000
African children of blindness and um the
movement uh actually kind of actively
starts to recruit and it finds it's it
finds the people most interested in the
movement in kind of math and physics
programs mainly at American Universities
at Elite American universities and one
of the movements Founders a fellow named
will mgal wellknown uh gives a talk in
Cambridge that Sam hears and the talk
the important parts of the talk are at
that point sammon knew about effective
altruism and was interested in its ideas
but effective altruism had spawn another
idea and it was it was earned to give
and this is what Sam here as will mgal
basically talk about and it's it's as
you 20-year-old college student who
doesn't know what you want to do with
your life think about what you want to
do with your life um consider the cons
cons consider this Choice let's make
this Choice explicit uh you could go
become a doctor and go work in Africa
and save so many lives uh or if you have
this aptitude That Wall Street craves
you could go to Wall Street and you can
make money enough to send 20 doctors to
Africa and save 20 times as as many
lives now What's Happening Here is your
life choices are being turned into a
math problem and Sam responded
powerfully to this and it was this earn
to give idea okay I'm going to go figure
out how to make as much money as
possible and essentially divorce it's
not going to be a matter of the heart
I'm not doing this because I'm feeling a
certain that that this is my way of
having the most impact on the world and
this is the beginning of the of Sam
bankman freed as a as a character in the
world that that he at the virtually the
same time without having I mean this is
not a person who's a money person he
does not grow up with like and never
really become someone who has much
interest in m in material things um and
his parents don't either kind of lives
in his head uh that that the idea that
it bewildered the parents that all of a
sudden the child is being recruited by
Wall Street firms and that this this
thing he can do and they've discovered
he can do and it and it pays not just a
few million dollars it might pay many
many many many millions of dollars so we
we'll come back to the money aspect a
bit later but just talk about that
aptitude so what is it about Sam bankman
freed that made him so good at high
frequency trading when he joined a Wall
Street firm so when I went through Wall
Street uh interviews back in the 1980s
they were they were they were their own
strange event mainly designed to sort of
test your nerve I mean they do just
weird things like uh
um generally what they were try to is
make you as uncomfortable as possible
and see how you responded and um the the
the interviews that identify Sam bankman
fre is possibly very gifted uh in a way
that The High Frequency Traders care
about and these are the firms by the way
these firms I mean unless you're in Wall
Street or in finance you may never have
heard of these places Jam Street Jam
Street jump trading Tower research um uh
Susana Capital uh Citadel vert these are
the names of the places and this is this
is a phenomenon of the last 15 years
they have it they are taking the
interesting risk in the markets now it's
no longer Goldman Sachs and Morgan
Stanley that are doing this that these
firms they are the ones who are
establishing market prices and and in
these places sums of money are being
made that dwarf the sums of money that
were made in their predecessors I mean
it used to be a big deal to make a
million dollars in a firm there are
people in these firms who make billions
of dollars um so Sam and the tests they
put you through and the kind of people
they're looking for a little different
social skills not important not at all
important it's it's what's important is
it's it's a mathness but it's not just a
ma it's a math combined with an ability
to deal with messiness so it's it's Sam
bman freed good at chess good at math
camp but not the very best not going to
be a famous mathematician not going to
be a chess champion but if instead you
change chess so that every move has to
be done within 10 seconds and every two
minutes uh some voice shouts a rule
change so Queens become pawns or pawns
can fly or whatever that it is it
doesn't matter
creating a kind of semi chaotic
environment that's the environment that
at least the the the people who were
recruiting for these firms think you
need to be good at in order to to thrive
um so and he also appears to be willing
to take risks where other people might
hesitate he jumps in correct but you you
have to be able to make decisions where
other people might be paralyzed and he
would say I think this is true that the
kind of problems they give you tend to
paral tend to cause people just to not
not make decisions and they looking for
people who will make decisions and make
them fairly quickly uh and so the um his
willingness to make the decisions was an
was an asset in this process um I mean
we could run we don't want to run
through any of these tests they're
incredbly they're incredibly Arcane what
they do to these and you look and you
say like how could how do you even think
about that problem if I mean one I mean
for example to to reduce to a
quantitative matter uh what's the
likelihood that I have a relative who
played professional baseball and to
think through that problem in a really
sophisticated way and do it quickly it's
one of the tests they put him through
and so and another way of thinking about
what they do is um learning how to
quantify things that you might think are
of as qualitative matters or qualitative
decisions he had the ability to do that
he he off the charts ability like when
he when he went through the the these um
interviews they would one of the firms
stop the interviews halfway through the
interviews and said we don't need to do
anymore you just outscored anybody this
year and his problem however is that
these tests and the problem these firms
have I think these tests do not filter
for any kind of social ability uh and
this is a person who to describe to
describe him as isolated doesn't fully
capture the the nature of the person um
this is a person who you know from a
very early age so when I ask him I mean
which you I would do would would do with
any subject give me a list of people uh
from the who knew you before the age of
18 so I can just get a sense of what
your child who was like he couldn't name
a person he his parents his brother was
off the list because his brother he
didn't have anything to do with his
brother and that I had to kind of dig
and dig and dig to find people who had
interaction with him before the age of
18 he felt he felt um uh first no real
feeling for people like in the presence
of people he didn't feel love he didn't
feel he said I didn't feel Pride I
didn't feel any of the things people
normally feel he said the thing I most
weirdly couldn't do is I couldn't make
facial expressions so when people were
interacting with me I wasn't giving they
they didn't know how to respond to me so
they just thought I was this weird thing
so he I don't go ahead you I was just
say he does at one time though talks
about talk about being depressed and I
wonder if that reflects the fact that he
does feel emotion but just perhaps not
in the way that you or I might I'm sure
feels something he thinks but he his
self-identity was I don't understand
other I don't understand these feelings
I don't I don't have these feelings and
he um and he was ostracized all the way
through childhood less so at MIT because
MIT tends to collect these people who
were ostracized by everybody else when
they're in high school but he was some
recognition there so I mean but you know
he was the kind of person who even the
Nerds rejected cuz he was such a nerd
right there was no spot for this in in
even in even in a private Silicon Valley
High School where his classmate is Steve
Jobs son that you would think that would
they'd be plenty of people who we could
not relate to who could not relate to
him and they would Bond over that but
but it that's not what happen Wonder
though if it develops later on just
jumping forward for a moment into a kind
of arrogance because he tells you at one
point that he doesn't struggle to read
other problem other people his problem
is that people can't read him and I
there's a little bit of me that thinks H
come on come on he was pretty good at
reading other people people I you know I
think he was surpr this is the this is
the part that doesn't fit the overall
picture that his astuteness about other
people um not always but better than you
would have imagined given how and the
point about other people reading him is
if he's not giving anything it's hard
right he when he is in college when he
starts to develop ambition to go to work
on Wall Street and he realizes that
there's there's been no social filter
but eventually there's going to be
problems because he can't do the social
thing he gets a mirror and he starts
practicing like how to smile and he's
resentful about it why do I need to grin
when you say something that's amusing
isn't it enough that I just listen but
he forces himself to learn these things
um so you say arrogance I agree it's and
it's the arrogance of a boy who sits in
a room thinking about the world and
watching the world for 18 years and
trying to position his himself in a way
that is not completely defeating um in
relation to that world and he had a
hollow sense of his own superiority
without anything really up to the point
he hits Wall Street with any kind of
evidence to suggest he is Superior in
any way he was he was never thought
extremely special until he hits Wall
Street so he's successful at Jane Street
uh successful Trader but then sees a gap
in the market and decides to leave and
create his own firm alamer research can
we do one thing before we move on from
Wall Street I don't interrupt your
interview no but this is something no
this never will get mentioned in the in
the in the processes what they did in
this firm is two chapters of the book
are just about this and it's riveting
what's going on in this place and I'm
going to give one
example Sam bankman freed and his a few
colleagues before the presidential
election 2016 it's crazy stuff right but
this will give you a wet your appetite
although you're all getting the bughin
way so I don't really need to do that
but but but the so so before the Clinton
Trump ra campaign or race during the
race before the election um they all
everybody notices like everybody in the
financial markets notices that whenever
there's good news for Trump the stock
markets collapse and whenever there's
good news for Clinton the stock markets
go up and they think to themselves I we
wonder if we can get information
real-time information on Election night
before anybody else in the world and
trade on it because it's obviously going
to move markets around and this is
audacious this is what these this is if
you ask what Sam bankr free and these
firms are doing what they're generally
they are they're they're looking for
they're looking to to get information no
one else has before anybody has it and
put it in the markets but on the level
of the second or the millisecond and so
they build an they they build a data
collection uh um machine where Traders
are assigned to states in the United
States to find better faster ways to get
the information from the polls and you
would think well how could that how
could they do that but the way up to
that point Americans are getting the
results of their election is on the ca
is on cable news and the cable it goes
to commercials the guy has to walk
across a set to his map there there all
these human things that are slowing down
the information arriving in the minds of
Wall Street people and they indeed build
this thing that enables them to have
sometimes minutes sometimes ours
advantages on the market about what's
happening in this election and it's Sam
is right in the middle of this this is a
sort of thing that completely captivates
him um they make a bet the bet is that
if as they see the Trump is going to win
that US Stock markets are going to
collapse they bet the foreign stock
markets are going to collapse too but
they make their big bet in the US Stock
markets that's what they do in the first
four or five hours after five hours
after the election they have the most
profitable trade in the history of Jane
Street they've made several hundred
million dollars in a matter of hours Sam
goes to bed for a few hours and comes
back and it's the worst trade in the
history of Jane Street because Market
have rallied the US markets have rallied
on the news of trump and they've lost
all this money this is this is re this
this what happens next tells you
something about Sam bankman freed he's
lost he's just orchestrated the worst
trade in the history of this firm The
Firm the way they think about things
they don't blame him the process was
fine everybody approved of it they don't
look to scapegoat him they just say like
we won't do this again one of the
reasons Sam bankman Freeds leaves Jan
street is he's upset they won't do this
again he says the problem wasn't that we
shouldn't have done this it's just we
should have thought about it a little
better how we traded it we should keep
doing this and he found there a lack of
ambition frustrating so that's it's an
amazing thing so then he finds crypto Al
made a research I'm going to spool
forward a little bit he gets funding
from effective altruists uh partly to
help Alam research do its work is that
right y yep um but there is at some
point a Schism right well this is a
foreshadowing of what what is going to
happen four billion dollar goes missing
and a whole bunch of people four million
four million four million in a pile four
million I apologize $4 million goes
missing uh and a bunch of people choose
to leave should alarm Bells have rung in
many people's minds at that moment about
s bankman freed and they did so what
happens is he's going to do he's going
to be the first highfrequency Trader
into crypto basically is the is the idea
um he moves to California at the end of
2017 and for for various reasons reasons
only recruits other effective altruists
to work in this hedge
fund none of are very only a couple of
whom had any real Financial experience
so they're 20 or so of them and within
months the firm is is in a civil war
because half the firms think Sam is
either a crook or so catastrophically SL
sloppy that he might as well be a crook
and they're missing they're they're
they're missing money like literally
don't know where it is and money that
has come to them from effective altruist
so they're thinking this money could
have gone to save lives in Africa
instead it's it's gone to fuel Sam
Beckman Freed's mad trading and now we
don't know what it is and Sam doesn't
care to go find it he wants to just keep
trading because he thinks it'll turn up
anyway so it did set off alarm Bill
Bells uh in in the effective altruist
Community because they were the only
ones privy to what was going on half the
people quit the firm including the
entire management committee apart from
Sam and
um and they find the money so that so
then it gets very complicated because
they've accused him of stealing the
money they've accused him of losing the
money and that uhoh actually the money's
there and actually these things he wants
to do make sense and it and he starts to
make a lot of money and I caught the
effective altruists who had left and had
accused him of wrongdoing in the moment
uh when things were going great for Sam
bankman freed and all but one of them
were sheepish and apologetic like we
should never have left we should have
trusted him uh but they they they were
all having second thoughts about the
Schism but the Schism actually is a
foreshadowing of what's going to happen
because the carelessness was
breathtaking and the the willingness to
take risk was breathtaking and also the
willingness to do things without
consulting anybody like they got to a
point in this firm where it was so scary
that all this money was missing they
made his fellow managers would make Sam
promise you can't hit the button and
send your Bots out there to make 250,000
trades a day unless we're here with you
to watch and he goes yeah okay and then
they go home for the night he hits the
button and falls asleep and and that
that was a kind of common occurrence so
it was a obvious recklessness that um
that gets buried it gets buried all the
people who were suspicious of him but
one there was an exception in management
ranks um and end up like rethinking
their suspicions and thinking oh no he
was actually very special and we should
have appreciated how special he was and
the people that remain to some extent
are True Believers two of them well this
shapes The Firm right so you've got two
of them who are in court uh this week
Gary Wang the coda and Caroline Ellison
I mean just two of the characters that
appear in the book that are still part
of the story how much do you think Sam
bankman freed was able to to behave in
the way that he did to go on to create
um FTX which appeared to be a company
without any controls without any of the
the normal structures you'd expect in a
company of that size can we talk a
little bit about that about the about
just how peculiar this was I mean it's
extraordinary yes please do let me let
me give one example and then I'll as to
illustrate the just the general chaos so
does anybody have the book on them right
now if if if you open the book and um
will you if you could you hand us the
cover just the jacket cover and can you
mind if I no not okay so so let me do I
can get up and do this I probably the
the this is uh breaking protocol with
the intelligence Square it's stand
actually standing up so but I'm going to
show you oh I want to show you something
because this this really does kind of
dramatize it so when the whole thing
falls apart um there
so when Sam B he he refused to he had a
principled objection to job titles and
organization charts and even having a
list of the employees who worked in The
Firm or anybody knowing the list of
employees who worked in the firm and he
saw the organization chart people see
where they are and it it distorts their
behavior towards each other they had a
long this is all in the story a long
explanation fire they wouldn't he
wouldn't do conventional organization of
course people need organ organization
and especially half his firm is Chinese
and they don't they just go insane
without an organization chart like it's
the most important thing in a Chinese
firm and and so Sam know and Sam would
subcontract all the dealing with the
other people's emotions and unhappiness
to other people in The Firm one of the
people to whom he subcontracts a large
part of this mess is his own
psychiatrist who he has flown from San
Francisco who has gone from San
Francisco where he was psychiatrist to
effective altruist that was his business
basically so he's got a wonderful view
on the whole effective altruist thing
comes to the Bahamas where he within
moments has a 100 FTX employees on his
couch coming through to talk about their
personal problems and the personal
problems are because all they do is work
are all job problems and the job
problems are mostly like I don't know
where I am in this organization I Hate
My Boss but I don't know who my boss is
it's it's that kind of stuff and and so
the
psychiatrist the psychiatrist in order
to treat these people starts to in
therapy asks them who's above them who's
below them who do they report to who do
they talk to and he creates an
organization chart but tells zero people
except me he doesn't Sam bman freed does
is in jail so he does not know this
exists he'd be outraged to know this
exists but the prosecutors don't know
this exists the bankruptcy people have
said over and over we don't know who
even work for this firm well here they
are every single name every single name
and it's beautifully done like
like U
so I don't need to screw up your book
cover we'll get it back but we'll sign
your book twice but the but you look at
it and it's like it's like one of those
uh family trees in a toll story novel
that that you this will this will help
you understand everything you read and
there are things on that they're just
beautiful I mean someone who's actually
a business consultant would take this
and say wait 24 people are reporting to
Sam how does that work and none of and
he won't talk to any of them but but but
Gary Wang who doesn't speak except when
he's on a witness stand Gary Wang who is
the who is the CTO who cooks up this
business with Sam who is meant to Chief
technology officer in a basically
technology firm he has no one underneath
him and that's because that's because
the therapist in the therapist didn't
know business but he knew that Gary
didn't talk to anybody so there must be
no one underneath it anyway anyway here
we we'll get we'll get you let's give
this back to you now there we go but
that's an example just a little example
of how this place functioned and it was
so wonderful for a writer's point of
view I wouldn't invest in it but from a
writer's point of view it was just
delightful because you never seen
anything like
it